we are told that pentagon a prime b
prime c prime d prime e prime which is
in red right over here is the image of
pentagon a b c d e under a dilation so
that's a b c d e what is the scale
factor of the dilation so they don't
even tell us the center of the dilation
but in order to figure out the scale
factor you just have to realize when you
do a dilation the distance between
corresponding points will change
according to the scale factor so for
example we could look at the distance
between point a
and point b right over here what is our
change in y
our change in or even what is our
distance our change in y is our distance
because we don't have a change in x well
this is one two three four five six so
this length right over here
is equal to six now what about the
corresponding side from a prime to b
prime well this length right over here
is equal to two and so you can see we
went from having a length of 6 to a
length of 2 so you'd have to multiply by
1 3. so our scale factor right over here
is 1 3. now you might be saying okay
that was pretty straightforward because
we had a very clear you could just see
the distance between a and b how would
you do it if you didn't have a vertical
or a horizontal line
well one way to think about it is the
changes in y and the changes in x would
scale accordingly so if you look at the
distance between point a and point e our
change in y
is negative three right over here and
our change in x is positive three right
over here and you can see over here
between a prime and e prime our change
in y is negative one which is one third
of negative 3 and our change in x is 1
which is 1 3 of 3. so once again you see
our scale factor
being one-third
let's do another example
so we are told that pentagon a prime b
prime c prime d prime e prime is the
image and they don't they haven't drawn
that here is the image of pentagon a b c
d e under a dilation with a scale factor
of five half so they're giving us our
scale factor
what is the length of segment a prime e
prime
so as i was mentioning while i read it
they didn't they didn't actually
draw this one out so how do we figure
out the length of a segment
well i encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about it
well they give us the scale factor and
so what it tells us if the scale factor
is five halves that means that the
corresponding lengths will change by a
factor of 5 halves so to figure out the
length of segment a prime e prime this
is going to be you could think of it as
the image of segment ae
and so you can see
that the length of a e
is equal to
and so the length of a prime
e prime
is going to be equal to
ae which is 2 times the scale factor
times 5 halves this is our scale factor
right over here and of course what's 2
times 5 halves well it is going to be
equal to 5 5 of these units right over
here so in this case we didn't even have
to draw a prime b prime c prime d prime
e prime in fact they haven't even given
us enough information i could draw the
scale of that but i actually don't know
where to put it because we didn't even
give us our center of dilation but we
know that corresponding sides or the
lengths between corresponding points are
going to be scaled by the scale factor
now with that in mind let's do another
example
so we are told that triangle a prime b
prime c prime which they depicted right
over here is the image of triangle abc
which they did not depict under a
dilation with a scale factor of two
what is the length of segment a b once
again they haven't drawn a b here how do
we figure it out well it's going to be a
similar way as the last example but here
they've given us the image and they
didn't give us the original so how do we
do it
well the key and pause the video again
and try to do it on your own
well the key realization here is that if
you take the length of segment a b
and you were to multiply by the scale
factor so you multiply it by two
then you're going to get the length of
segment a prime b prime
the image is length is equal to the
scale factor times the corresponding
length on our original our original
triangle
so what is the length of a prime b prime
well this is straightforward to figure
out it is 1 two three four five six
seven eight so this right over here is
eight so we have two times the length of
segment a b
is equal to eight and then you get the
length of segment a b just divide both
sides by 2 is equal to 4 and we're done